so first off congratulations thank you
so much one of the things that
fascinates me about your movie is how
many really lengthy winners you have so
going into this shoot which one or did
you think would be the most challenging
to get but then which is the one that
proved most challenging when you were
physically on set doing it i i think
the
actually the one i thought would be most
challenging is this the first one with
the like first one with a lion
it's only because it was so many
characters and and and
you know
the vfx lions and the people presenting
the vfx lions and trying to get that all
in into one shot and flow which is when
xalto
and
idris us you know step out of the out of
the car and walk up to the alliance and
you have like what five people
no
no yes five people and and and
bunch of lions and two of them
interacting with the character and i
thought it would be but
to my surprise it wasn't that one who
turned out to be the most complicated
it's actually when the lion attacks the
car for the first time because that was
so much handing over camera and and and
running with idris and and that was that
was one of the first shot that i kind of
created in my mind to say so
because from very
very early
i realized i wanted to try to set this
film apart from other films of this
genre
and and and try to
bring something different to the table
you know and because you've seen
jurassic park who have way bigger
budgets and bigger creatures and and so
like
by by
getting you stuck in a shot
to up the
emotion of claustrophobia being stuck to
being one of the characters in the
situation so i was very adamant about
you know presenting this to the studio
and having them approve because
it's an unusual way of shooting
blockbusters you know and
and uh and i got there you know they i
convinced them and and i think they were
very pleased when you saw the outcome
but
for me it's all about that
giving the feeling that you are
there with the characters so it feels
more uh point of view so you're really
never cutting to the lie on what's
coming and so on and so very successful
in that respect and it does feel unique
to jurassic park but that's my favorite
movie of all time so the jurassic park
tinges peppered throughout this movie
just filled my heart i loved it um i
have to talk about your cinematographer
philippe rousseau is just like one of
the most incredible cinematographers out
there academy award nominated but what
is it about his previous work that made
you think like he can do these wonders
but he's also able to do what i need him
to do in order to make these vfx work
well uh
first of all he had uh
he had done
both his older films it's like you know
queen mark got you know the french movie
uh that the the the
you know river runs through it i think
is one and then uh fantastic beasts so
he obviously has a long history and also
a long range uh i like his men like
sensuality like his friend's sensibility
you know accessibility in this filming
and his lighting which i was going after
there's nothing in his work that
suggested that he could do this oneness
and when i suggested already he had
signed on and i told him i didn't tell
him
at that point i told him this was the
way we were going and he i think he was
pretty
scared you know but and then again i
have done a bit of it not at to this
extent at all
and i enjoyed the part of the work a lot
you know creating the movement and the
choreography and also some of it is uh
uh preconceived done with the
storyboards and stuff like that and then
some of it is also just worked on on set
you know because there's always a
element that comes to your surprise but
also had a great uh operator called dale
a south african uh guy who was
tremendous help both for me and philippe
so so together we we solved this but
felipe was a little yeah he was a little
overwhelmed
in the beginning and he's he's an older
gentleman so so in all respect that was
uh but i think he was extremely happy
both when he
when he got through it and also when he
saw the result of the film he was like
you know he's like i think he was
surprised how how how well this came
together he's a pro but going into
something like this you better be a
little nervous otherwise yeah yeah
that's right it's fun you know like you
know you know you've been doing it for
the last 50 years somebody's gotta you
know put you off your off your kilter a
little bit all right i have a feeling i
know the answer to this question but do
you view the roguelion as a villain in
this movie not really to be honest i
never uh see nature us as us as the the
villain i always see
what we are doing to nature and and how
nature uh strikes back let's say a
tsunami hits us you can't really blame
the tsunami can you you there's a reason
for the tsunami or or you know sometimes
it's nature itself protecting itself and
sometimes is what we do to to nature and
in this case it's very clearly stated in
the movie that the villains are
the poachers and the people taking their
lands and
forcing into this situation and nature
does strike back and there are there are
stories of lions doing this but they
usually attack indigenous people so
western culture
isn't necessarily
as aware of it as like sharks so the
other parts of that question then is
when you're shooting the more thrilling
sequences where the lion is attacking
the family how do you make it so the
audience is rooting for the family to
survive and take down the lion as they
have to in order to get out of this
situation but never letting the audience
forget that it wasn't that roguelion's
fault to begin with i think it's
important first of all
uh
a
a villain or or or which which would as
i said the lion isn't but like as like a
good
exciting
antagonist or somebody up against it's
very important you know you are
fascinated by like a great in a movie
you you know like you like the villain
to be kind of sexy and a little bit you
know
interesting and and in some way by
creating a lion particularly you know as
a character not as any lion you know
i want people to be fascinated by a lion
they should be aware of the dangers of
it but then when they compliment
contemplate the movie they're also aware
it isn't the lion's fault lions do not
are not born on this on on this earth to
attack
people you know so so so but but i think
the situation is very clearly uh
stated in the film but at at the same
time you you have to have a
uh worthy opponent you know and i think
you know and and i i told many of but
for example brad pitt is nuts was a
little bit uh what's a little bit the
idea for the lion lean mean and fast and
and predictable yeah and yeah and then
so you have to you know look at it not
only as a a chunk of maid or an animal
you have to look it as a real character
and and and we put a lot of work into
creating a character and finding
references of lions that we we liked and
felt that they would present this line
in a different way this quite you can
see it's very different from the lands
in the beginning who are much kind of
calmer
you